you can see it's coming from
this way in
it has to because my elbow is going to
be
at the yin line and my hands going to be
at the neutral line my hand's not out
yet
so as he squares his hips on the step
through
this shoulder has to come forward
and of course it's not only moving this
way
but it's moving that way
and this is another reason why you don't
do tai no hanko like that
so this hand is going forward
and in therefore
any movement that is not allowing it to
go forward and
in is a clash on that hand
also his fingers
are closing and going back on the other
way
of his grip so anything that is going
against the closing of those fingers
is also a clash
hence we go like this
this is going against the fingers
i have to get his grip
and turn it and allow his energy to keep
going
as i rotate the cross
he presented the cross and i turned the
cross
so what was the cross and he had a north
south east
west to his movement and i just rotate
the cross
and then i rotate the cross then
everything gets
reorganized yin becomes young young
becomes
in everything turn
okay let's try it okay so this concept
of
juji we use over and over but we use
lots of concepts so we have to use judy
in a particular way and
we have an inward spiral and we have an
outward spiral and they
too have a particular way what is that
way
i cannot activate the deltoids i have to
deactivate the deltoids the deltoid
is an inferior muscle group for doing
things moving things
in or moving things out it's a weak
point
in the combative structure so i will
need
go ahead do whatever i need things to be
able to go in
but i cannot use my deltoid to do that
it's very very weak it's inferior
hence these spirals okay so we'll go
back to this drill
the first drill here please and we have
this drill so the inward turning spiral
was practiced in eco and then the hour
turning spirals and
tokyo ball but it's in every technique
you just repeat that over and over
okay so when i do the first
turning of the juju you can see that it
is the outward
it's part of the outward turning spiral
i cannot do that
in a way where i'm
using my deltoid the inner deltoid here
so it has to follow the pattern
you should be able to find the cocky
hole
just by extending that little
[Music]
if you have some weirdness which usually
is this is too close to my body
you're going to see that you can't get
that technique
and you if you're honest you're using
your deltoid to do
the technique so instead it's going to
be right
the gigi turns and
turn
again i don't prioritize knocking them
down
and really go like that because again
that's going to be outer deltoid
so it's a green of the shoal
it using
the deltoid freeing harmonizing
then not using the deltoid the spiral
instead
harmonizing no deltoid
don't come back keep the spiral going
for the outward turning spiral
okay let's see the inward and the
outward turning spirals do not
free us from having to use the deltoid
by some sort of talismanic power
what happens is the thing that i want to
move from into out or from out to in
is brought forward into its cycle of
action
and is now actually going in the other
direction that i
that i wanted to go so when he goes
around here i
do the juji harmonization to go back
into him now is going to be
my deltoid no matter what okay but by
continuing the cycle do you see he's
coming forward
into it and which way is he falling he's
falling that way already
so you want to in these drills you want
to complete
the spiral so
not um
here not back forward whoa
then he's going backwards now the other
way
so i'll do it here this is now going
back
some magic thing you think is gonna
happen
here juji reconciliation
then i'm going to do my spiral knot back
here
forward
some of you understand that the deltoid
is using but you're finding another
engine is you're going here and you're
going around him
you're trying to get energy by going
around him
that makes him the center of the
technique you want to be the center of
the technique so he goes around
you
[Music]
if you become infatuated with shoving
them back
you'll never get it you should need to
be infatuated with bringing him forward
and getting his light and the float
he won't float if he doesn't come
forward you actually pin
him so become infatuated with
that oh there it is drill is over
reconcile boom float drill is over
be infatuated with that so uh
let's say he's down i'm just much taller
than him
he comes to grab me and it always goes
you always that that's what you're
picturing happening
i'm just i'm i'm more powerful i put it
in his face and can't
it's not true that's not where
the throw happens
even with this height advantage he could
stop it
a joke in that amount of time he can
move he can draw a weapon he can let go
he can change everything
that's not where the throw happens that
is not where the ark is
the art is in not contesting
not overpowering in deconstructing the
conflict
not psychologically not ethnically
physically energetically so that's why i
turned this to go anywhere else but
where i'm telling you to go
with this hand is going to be a yangon
yang
this hand has to keep going forward
and that's where he gets light he gets
light here
you see
not you go here you're going to give him
back
everything you gain you see his balance
reconcile
reconciled this is it
this part of the hour turning spiral
that is in a technique like coquiho
is what we're doing in jordan
i do this so let's pay attention now
to just that portion
my elbow i'm going to divide my body
i have a line at my shoulder a line
halfway to my center line
my center line halfway to my shoulder
and shoulder
it is very important this is telling me
where my hands can go
and can't go so they do those spirals
so i keep energy reconciled and i don't
use my aerodeltoid and do a young
young conflict so
my i don't ever have my hand
my elbow and my shoulder in the same
line it is already wrong
you can already tell you're using your
deltoid when you do when he does this
he's pushing on me and i can feel it in
my deltoid
so my hand will be on my center my elbow
will be
on that halfway line
and when i do the spiral they do the
juji
a little slower the elbow is going to
move
and trade places and come to the center
line
for the spiral to continue in the
technique
it's going to go all the way you see
coming all the way to the next halfway
and the hand goes to the shoulder line
that's where you get that flow
if you watch it now from that pattern
you don't get there you keep your elbow
at the center line you don't go to the
halfway
your hand is at the halfway you see that
this is where you shove him
you have to fulfill the pattern whoa
whoa that's the float right there
so for joedon's pistol bucky
starts here elbow comes to the center
line
we won't go past that elbow
comes to the center line right here
go back to the initial drill with the
juji and elbow comes to my center line
don't change this
it's the same kata dirty angle
elbow central
elbow center one
this angle too does not change don't
bring your elbow in
next to your body
the gg has to happen in that geometry
and you must see the outward spiral you
must see
oh if i kept that elbow going i would
get the outer spiral
okay go back to drill away
when this line goes from
the yin position to the transition
position
at the elbow then that is where this
other
elbow will come in
so it was again
at the inline it'll meet in the center
line
and it will begin
the outward spiral
outward spiral and go into
the inward spiral which i'll show you
what
so again the inward spiral wasn't here
i'm going to use that to actually be
outward okay so i'm going around like
this
and this hand is going to go like this
but how we're moving it moves him that
way
reconcile this way
here
because to do this
is my outer deltoid
so elbow full bone
and to that i have my movement
so the fight has rotated don't go here
out we're not allowed to do that
use your spiral wall spirals going
in and i move
boom
so this is freaking you out
if you pay attention imagine someone's
grabbing me here
and i'm going that way well if you look
at my elbow my elbow went that way
so that's what i'm using you see
i don't go here and then move now
and i have the same floating
this is where i float him
go this way you're gonna pin him
whoa
[Music]
this way whoa
reconcile wreck this up
and again don't
lost after this big throwback
lust after whom the float
[Music]
using the grid pattern again
line line line line line
so halfway
center line center line and
it's going to go again
to that halfway line
so i'm going to show you a couple of
things it lets you know if you're doing
it right
outside of the grid so this goes halfway
line
center line this picks up at center line
and then this because it's doing that
gets to
halfway lying
aside from the grid if you watch his
body
he'll come forward and he'll come
forward
because as i said this elbow is actually
going
this way but not with my deltoid
it's coming around
and just like his head was here his head
is going
forward to get the flow
he's going forward to go that way
long forward
well second point
what you see instead on your technique
is he stays still you go here
and you move around that and then he
keeps his hand there
for lord knows what reason
so the rules of kihon is he has a
prescribed energy so he has to do it
and i reconcile the energy okay
so he hasn't done some weird counter he
has to finish that first energy
but when you leave him there and he
stands over here and he leaves that hand
there
you gave him a choreography to do
what i'm doing is trading contact points
no different then i pulled this then i
pulled out and then i pulled that
he has nothing to do with him
i want to grab this
[Music]
so i moved that and i move this
so he's holding on i haven't cleared the
hand so he's gonna hold on
and now i make contact here he can do
whatever he wants with his hand he could
do whatever he wants with his hand
it doesn't have anything to do with me
a lot of times you'll he'll have
explanation
he sh he has to keep his guard up
he does not have to keep his guard head
so like if he meaning for example
if he doesn't keep that connection
right that connection he doesn't keep it
then i'm just gonna hit him well he
could hit me too
and if i felt trapped i would dismantle
the trap
not keep myself trapped so for example
if he has a knife and i have a knife
and he goes i am not going to go
well i could stab him and he could stab
me
if he comes off and i stab him
that's an iuchi then that could happen
in anything
with his empty hand a counter for
example so
for example i come in
he goes if my hand can move i can do my
stuff back
i can come in and move and tackle and do
whatever
that's not what we're doing and your
opponent will always be able to do that
if you don't keep this connection going
so if there's ever standing still
as you move around this is not it
you pay attention you did not do this
part here
you did not do that part there
so you can go slow because it's a little
different because you're like
i don't understand how by going in he
goes that way
okay just relax
just follow the grid all of the great
okay
i'm on the center line and this elbow
has to go around
to the next in line
then next center line center line
it's going to be like your wall
next go ahead and move there's no reason
why you can't
[Music]
move
so i don't need any hooks
to move him to bring him around or
anything
i don't want that i want him going that
way you go that way dude get away
you don't want to be on the outside and
turn the guy towards you
these spirals allow you to stay on the
outside
and have him go in the direction that we
want him to go without turning him
towards me
just like pokey hole allows the guy to
go backwards but
by going forward
[Music]
okay okay so a technique i'm doing
joedon testabaki
in a technique like i'm going to just
keep doing
the same spiral so here is the inward
spiral
on the hook and then when he comes out
if i see the our spiral
boom there's imagine someone here
there's your
coquiho and then you have to go
everywhere spiral again
so our spiral inward spiral
inward spiral outward spiral
inward spiral
g pull
[Music]
following all the rules
on the grid wolves
[Music]
different
okay so if i don't do these spirals
then that's where you're going to use
that our deltoid
it's not going to be strong enough it's
not the art
it doesn't reconcile because it doesn't
continually do
the juji rotation on every conflict
point
so conflict points as i described here
there here is another conflict point so
he's going to straighten his arm and i'm
going to straighten my arm and there is
another jiuji
so i'm going to not go
here that's me trying to cut across
the juji i'm going to turn the jiuji
so his arms going up
my arm is going here it turned
and it's going this way
this way
i am continually doing that so
let's pay attention to the grid
the elbow comes to the center line the
transition
this yin yang and this yin yang that's
where the other
one starts comes around
here's my other juji here
and i started going the elbow
here not here always that midpoint do
you see
and where does it go boom around
and it's back on my midline he comes up
i'll show you as i come around you see
midline
here and that starts
the coq hole and where does it go
to the other yin line here
so midline
[Music]
at midline is where this one starts to
make contact
but does not become yogg until this
elbow hits the yin line over here
as he's already falling
so midline transition line
midline midline transition line makes
contact but does not get used
goes to the midline here now this is on
the transition line and it completes by
going to the midline on the other side
home midline transition line midline
transition line
midline transition line boom
moment
don't have things outside your body
outside your body no
they always meet one hand brings the
energy to the center line
that's where the other line can take it
over cannot take it over over here
you're going to use your deltoid
complete the cycle
boom complete the cycle boom
complete the cycle here it comes in
[Music]
so pay attention how they will meet
several times here
on the transition line the center line
of my body
the elbows line
boom central hunt
then they trade places on which is the
yongnan
okay